if
your kid's got some free time coming up
this summer there was a new summer camp
that your child can go to chris ruffo
the the crt guy has just uh found this
little gem
it's a it's a camp
for your child to learn about sex ed
and that's good we've all been told you
need comprehensive sex ed health
education that's just responsible that's
just following the science there's
nothing radical about that
it's just the right responsible thing to
do
it's called sexy sex ed
it is
a quote a workshop series that compels
teenagers and people of all ages to
openly discuss personal and political
consent
sexual safety and anatomy
i love this word compels
it's not impels which would be to you
know push along it's not uh persuades or
encourages no it's compels they're going
to force these kids and people of all
ages to openly discuss personal and
political consent sexual safety and
anatomy okay so what are some of the
workshops we've got oh i just downloaded
it from the sexy sex ed website we've
got um
okay the very first workshop this is on
july 6th
it's a tuesday mark your calendar is sex
with me a self-pleasure workshop
participants will explore personal views
on self-pleasure as well as learn
techniques
to make the most out of their yeah i'm
not you i'm you know
this is a family show some kids listen
to this i'm going to clean up some of
the language here to make the most out
of
what woody allen called sex with someone
you love
this workshop will include discussion
games
and some hands-on practice
now they they add here at the end on
hands so maybe that's just like a joke
and a pond in you
you just
you do some creepy stuff to your own
hand i don't know i don't want to know
uh gender diversity that one's on
tuesday it's the following week tuesday
the 13th so your child can learn about
how if he wants to chop off his genitals
and mutilate his body he can pretend to
be
another type of sex
uh let's talk about sex sexy trans sexa
there's that self-managed abortion
that's good that's that's what
nine-year-olds and ten-year-olds should
learn about right
then there's sex on drugs you've got to
learn about sex on drugs
i don't know if that's are they
discouraging i assume they're
encouraging that
uh and then there's a closing ceremony
there's lots of other creepy stuff in
there too but
you get the picture and so you're
reading that you think gosh that's
that kind of goes beyond just science
you know that seems not just like you're
presenting relevant responsible
scientific information to your child
that seems to be ideological that seems
to have a political
cultural even spiritual
dimension to it
right because you're discussing moral
issues here and then
the real
cherry on top of this sunday is you look
into who runs this sexy summer camp
totally just responsible scientific
information for people of all ages and
the person who runs it is a
self-described
witch
yes we have
uh taney
taney is
a
a femme
femme fat queer magical pleasure worker
educator and artist she was raised in
rural kentucky by a host of witchy women
alongside sisters and cousins
uh a coven like mountain matriarchy if
you will her craft tools are candles
crystals oils plants music sex toys
tarot cards the moon and the instincts
of a triple water sign
she started the appalachian sex ed
collective called sexy sex ed
with over a decade of rural organizing
practice toward healing abolition and
liberation she fantasizes about a whole
other world
tanya lives high on a kentucky
mountaintop with lots of plants a steamy
hot tub and several furry familiars
for those who are not familiar with the
storm familiars that's
like the cat
that witches will use
to carry out their schemes that's that's
actually what that word means that's
what she's referring to you can join her
coven over at patreon
capitalism always wins in the end right
even for the witches hey donate to my
patreon hey go over to my gofundme so
this is how tanya taney describes her
camp
deal with yourself explore your own body
masturbation is really healthy and i
recommend it to people of all ages
all ages as soon as my nephews could
talk they were doing that that's what
they were doing kids touch themselves
kids start to ask questions and we teach
them the language for their bodies right
that's your nose touch your nose show
aunt t you can touch your nose but my
sister's not saying that when they're
tugging at their penis right
but it feels good right we have to learn
ways to talk to young people about this
so that they know how to explore their
body consensually so that it's not in
public right we don't want people
exploring their bodies in public that's
not consensual
but exploring your body at any age
grandmas grandpas all of us need to be
exploring we need to be exploring all of
all of our bodies whether you're a
three-year-old and well don't worry
we'll teach you how to do it
three-year-old just like my nephews
three-year-old maybe some grandparents
too that's what we've got to do i'm a
witchy woman i'm literally telling you
i'm a witch right now i do witchcraft
i'm a part of the witch religion and so
send your kids to me for summer camp
and what do what do the liberals do they
kind of laugh about this they say oh
oh she's a witchy woman you're like
you're like hillary you're a nat you're
a nasty woman
well-behaved women seldom make history
at one time i was interviewing uh greg
jarrett the fox news journalist about a
new book that he was doing
and it was it was called witch hunt i
think that was the title of the book
that was at least the theme of the book
that donald trump was subject to a witch
hunt and he made this point on the air
he said the thing about witch hunts
michael is that there's no such thing as
witches and i just i let him go on and
pitch the book and he's a nice guy and
he's a good journalist
but that point really stuck with me
because
he's wrong he's totally wrong this might
be one of my less popular views but it
happens to be correct
witches are totally real they're
obviously real
every culture throughout all of history
has believed in witches there are people
right now who call themselves witches
one of the fastest growing cults in
america is the wicca cult what is wicca
wicca is just witchcraft by its own
definition that's what it is
this woman when people tell you who they
are
believe them
well what does that mean does that mean
that they fly around on broomsticks
probably not
not i'm not gonna say it's a zero
percent chance but probably they don't
have green skin and pointy hats and fly
around on broomsticks but they do lots
of weird occult rituals and there is
more in heaven and earth horatio than is
dreamt of in our philosophy
this workshop is the perfect example of
this of what we talk about frankly a lot
on this show
the way that sex ed is presented
or is sold to the public when people
want to put it in schools and other
community groups is they say look this
is just science it's just science it's
just this is how the body works and
there's no moral aspect or spiritual
aspect or anything like that
then how come it's always the witches
doing it you know how come it's all
when you look into
vice when you look into lots of
nasty things in our culture whether it's
this creep trying to groom children or
whether it's
porn or whether it's drug culture or
whether it's all the kind of seedy
underbelly of society
you'll notice that it's got a lot of
symbolism to it
there's always a kind of
devilish symbolism to it
you see it throughout all of these
things you'll notice that people who are
really into this stuff they embrace kind
of weird
symbolism they embrace weird identities
they call themselves witches why is that
is that just like a funny weird
eccentric quirk or is there maybe a
connection here is there maybe a
connection between the metaphysical
world and the physical world
is it may be the case that all politics
is not merely cultural but actually at
bottom theological and all human
conflict maybe is theological one thing
i know at the political level
is
that stuff is not going to play in
peoria okay and what we should do is
play those commercials again and again
and again and say this is what these
creeps want to do to your kids that's
what won glen younkin the race in
virginia to become governor of virginia
he said they want to brainwash your kids
into this crazy stuff
i'm glad that you liked that clip if you
want more clips ring the bell subscribe
get notifications also what i would
strongly recommend is you go to your
podcast app apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show it's very easy click subscribe
if you would be so kind maybe leave a
five star review
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you